good morning John happy holidays did
everybody I hope you're all enjoying
your holiday break if you get a holiday
break the time for contemplation two
sets of identical twins got married with
their kids be siblings or cousins
slaying with you present and coloring in
nude nudes because in four o'clock in
the morning on December 18th you decided
that that would be a really good way to
spend a good portion of your life 300
pieces of Hank oarfish art though almost
done I have become extremely good at
drawing hangar fish if I've learned
anything over the last year it's that if
you do something ten thousand dimes you
get pretty good at it
the first module an anglerfish it was
like I guess like and then the fin tail
fit ah oh what dr. puss with the fail on
how to get the dangle like Oh God and
now I'm like swoop chicken swoop back
line line line line line again and then
with a fan and thence teeth and then you
get this dangle in line I would be lying
if I said I wasn't actually pretty proud
of this I think there's something about
becoming an adult that like you're not
supposed to be proud of your
accomplishments anymore I'm out of debt
or I got a job or a new car or I can
afford a couch oh you're an adult what
do you want a cookie yes I want a cookie
I'm gonna go get cookie ain't have any
cookies but we did have these terrible
doughnuts that the USDA says has 45% of
my daily allowed saturated fat well of
the USDA decide what's healthy to put in
a food anyway there's a Department of
Agriculture I don't think that that will
be decided by the Department of Health
and Human Services which was responsible
for the health of America's not by the
USDA which is responsible the health of
the agriculture industry I'm paying
attention to either of them cuz don't
know which brings me back to what we
were originally talking about not really
which is new dudes not really
tangentially the project for awesome so
we raised let's be honest more money
than anybody expect we had originally
planned to split the money between the
charities featuring the top five
products for awesome videos but then it
was like oh we've enough money in the
account that I feel like we could expand
the pool and still have people getting
more money than we expected so we're
talking about expanding it to spread the
love to ten
charities now of course this isn't what
we originally planned on doing so I
wanted to leave it up to the community
to decide so there's a pole in our pants
which is there's a link in the
description if you would like to vote on
whether the money is split between five
charities or ten charities we're
thinking I might be nice to have more
winners and also that the money would do
more good if it went to more charities
now I leave you with another thing you
should be doing this holiday season if
you can sledding with the ones you love
do not know how this is gonna go
probably poorly sure face splitting
because your face your hat looks fine
you're very pretty
all right definitely gonna go worries
we're going headfirst this time good
first head first
don't poke the camera whoa there she is
here she comes there she goes backwards
oh yeah aftermath
this is how we get back to the car here
and zoo John this was a weird video I'll
see you on Tuesday
yeah it's like having two satellite
dishes on your head get all the good
channels